Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一个正在进行的令人兴奋的好消息。如果你曾想过如何创造能为你带来源源不断收入的管道，而不是把时间无休止地出卖给金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“冲刺持续性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, I am talking to Dr. Victoria Walker, a trainee clinical
这些原则同样适用于你。丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的专属链接参加挑战赛，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士一对一咨询一小时的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请访问我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我将为你提供所有详细信息。好啦，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我将对话维多利亚·沃克（Victoria Walker）博士，她是一位临床心理学实习生。
psychologist. We are talking about what it's like to have a long-term health condition, as well as go through a diagnostic and assessment process for an autistic spectrum disorder condition. I hope you'll find it so useful. And of course, at the end, Victoria will be offering you her top tips for reducing burnout as an aspiring psychologist. Hope you find it so useful. then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. So we are in the middle of application season for the doctorate in clinical psychology and I hope that your own application form is going well and similarly the
我们将探讨患有长期健康状况是怎样一种体验，以及经历自闭症谱系障碍（ASD）的诊断和评估过程是怎样的。希望你会觉得这非常有用。当然，在节目最后，维多利亚还将为你分享她作为一名有志成为心理学家的过来人，在减少职业倦怠方面的顶级建议。希望你会觉得它非常有用。那么就让本期播客伴随你左右，成为你通往执业之路的指南。这里是有志心理学家播客，我是玛丽安博士。嗨，欢迎来到有志心理学家播客。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名职业临床心理学家。目前我们正处于临床心理学博士项目申请季的中间阶段，我希望你们的申请表进展顺利。同样地，
educational psychology route for funded places is also in the application stage as well so if that is your bag I hope that is going well too. Don't forget if you would like to watch any Q&A sessions for the Compassionate Q&A which is where I give you my top tips and guidance for free about how to go about completing your clinical form, then you can watch the replays on my YouTube channel, Dr. Marianne Trent. I will give you the dates to look for so you know what you're looking for. So the first one of those took place on Monday, the 4th of September, 2023. And the second one is Tuesday, the 3rd of October, 2023 at 6 p.m. Depending on when this episode goes out, that might well be around the time when this episode is going out.
提供资助名额的教育心理学路线也正在进行申请，所以如果那是你的目标，我希望一切也都进展顺利。别忘了，如果你想观看“同理心问答”（Compassionate Q&A）的任何问答环节——正是在这个环节中，我免费向你提供关于如何完成临床申请表的顶级建议和指导——你可以在我的 YouTube 频道“Dr. Marianne Trent”上观看回放。我会把日期告诉你，方便你查找。其中第一场是在 2023 年 9 月 4 日星期一举行；第二场是 2023 年 10 月 3 日星期二晚上 6 点。根据这期节目的发布时间，那可能正好是本期节目上线的时间左右。
So do keep an eye out, look at the calendar when you're listening to this workout, whether that is before or after now, the Tuesday, the 3rd of October, 2023 at 6pm. And then the final one in this series of interview compassionate Q&As is Tuesday, the 7th of November, 2023 at 6pm. And this episode will definitely be out before that. But yeah, the replays are available on my YouTube. It's probably worth saying that I know some people will listen to these episodes years in advance. So the replays are always available. And there is a playlist called free Q&A sessions. And so you can check that out. If you would welcome some more tailored advice and support, do consider coming along to the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join with no minimum commitment for £30 a month. And there will be some information on screen if you are watching that on YouTube or in the show notes, or you can click any of the links in my social channels for more information.
所以请密切关注，听这期节目时查一下日历，看看现在是在那个时间之前还是之后——也就是 2023 年 10 月 3 日星期二晚上 6 点。这一系列访谈式同理心问答的最后一场是在 2023 年 11 月 7 日星期二晚上 6 点。这期节目绝对会在那之前发布。不过话说回来，回放都可以在我的 YouTube 上找到。顺便提一句，我知道有些人可能会在几年后才听到这些节目，所以回放一直都是可以观看的。那里有一个名为“免费问答环节”（free Q&A sessions）的播放列表，大家可以去查看。如果你希望获得更多量身定制的建议和支持，请考虑加入“有志心理学家会员计划”（the Aspiring Psychologist membership），只需每月 30 英镑，即可随时退出，无最低承诺期限。如果你在 YouTube 上观看本期节目，屏幕上会显示相关信息，也可以在节目简介中查看，或者点击我社交渠道中的任何链接了解更多信息。
And do bear in mind there is the free Facebook group as well, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. It would be remiss of me not to remind you about how wonderfully nourishing and helpful The Aspiring Psychologist Collective books and The Clinical Psychologist Coll collective book is too. So the content for today's podcast episode is all about long-term health conditions and autistic spectrum disorder. I hope you will find it useful for your own knowledge base but also for kind of when you're working in clinical or health populations where it might well be relevant. I hope you find it so useful and I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome along our guest for today's episode. I want to be also one of the very first people to introduce her as
请记住，还有一个免费的 Facebook 群组，名为“有志心理学家社群——对话玛丽安·特伦特博士”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent）。如果我不提醒大家《有志心理学家集锦》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）系列书籍和《临床心理学家集锦》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）系列书籍是多么滋养和有帮助，那就是我的失职了。所以今天播客节目的内容主要关于长期健康状况和自闭症谱系障碍。我希望这些内容不仅能丰富你自身的知识储备，而且在你未来接触到相关临床或健康群体时也能派上用场。希望你觉得这非常有用，我期待在节目后半部分与你交流。嗨，我只想欢迎今天节目的嘉宾来到现场。同时我也想成为最早向大家介绍她的人之一，
Dr Victoria Walker. Hi Victoria, welcome along to the podcast. Hi, thank you so much for having me. You're so welcome. You are very newly doctor because you've just got to the end of your doctoral training as a clinical psychologist, haven't you? Yes, so I finished last week, which is a very strange feeling. So, yeah, seeing Dr. Victoria Walker is going to take some getting used to. But with the caveat that I'm pending HCPC registration at the moment the documents are on the way. Well may they may they hasten themselves to you so that you can start claiming your band seven pay and you know start to walk in the shoes of those qualified psychologists the shoes can feel a little bit big to begin with but
她就是维多利亚·沃克博士。嗨，维多利亚，欢迎来到本期播客。嗨，非常感谢邀请我。不用客气。你是一位非常年轻的“博士”，因为你刚刚完成临床心理学博士培训，对吗？是的，我上周刚结束，这感觉非常奇妙。所以，嗯，听到别人叫我“维多利亚·沃克博士”还需要时间去习惯。不过前提是我的 HCPC（英国健康与护理专业委员会）注册目前还在审批中，相关文件正在路上。祝愿它们快点送到你手上，这样你就可以开始申领你的第七级（Band 7）薪资，并真正开始以合格心理学家的身份行事了。一开始这种角色可能会让人觉得有点难以驾驭，但
you've absolutely you've absolutely earned them so well done to you congratulations thank you and you um are part of the cohort um across the country who did your um interviews during lockdown aren't you? Yeah so I interviewed for a couple of courses just before the lockdown was all implemented across the country so we had our invites sent out maybe February 2020 to say yep you've got your interviews it's going to be in person at such and such a place I think one had offered a lunch which I was really looking forward to and then yeah in comes March and we went into lockdown and then obviously the courses had to just completely pretty much overnight change how they were doing things. So I can't imagine how stressful that must have been for people who were organising the interviews.
你绝对是实至名归，所以干得漂亮，恭喜你！谢谢。你也是全国范围内在封锁期间进行面试的那批学员之一，对吗？是的，我在全国实施封锁前不久参加了几个课程的面试。大概在 2020 年 2 月左右，我们收到了面试邀请，通知说：“好的，你获得了面试资格，面试将在某某地点的线下进行。”其中一个课程还提供午餐，我当时非常期待。然后，嗯，3 月份就来了，我们进入了封锁状态。显然，各个课程不得不几乎在短短一夜之间彻底改变运作方式。我简直无法想象这对组织面试的人来说有多大压力。
And I hadn't heard of Zoom or Teams at that point either. So it was a bit of an anxious wait to find out what on earth was going to happen. But then, yeah, interviewed end of March 2020, which feels world away now um and a very different uh a very different time absolutely and you've gone through all of your training with probably lots of things being remote I guess lots of your clinical placements have been in person but perhaps sometimes aspects of that have been remote as well yeah um it's been a bit of a mixed bag really. So for our first year all the teaching was online. So that was a, I mean I wouldn't know what the experience would be like because I've never been a trainee clinical psychologist before, but I can imagine it's very different to the cohorts that are starting now and all get to meet in person.
那时我甚至没听说过 Zoom 或 Teams。所以为了弄清楚到底会发生什么，经历了一段焦虑的等待。不过随后，我在 2020 年 3 月底参加了面试。现在回想起来，那感觉仿佛已经是另一个世界了，那是一个非常不同、非常特殊的时期。确实如此。而且考虑到你的整个培训过程中，大概有很多事情都是远程进行的，虽然你的很多临床实习可能是线下的，但有时某些方面也可能是远程的吧？是的，这其实是一个混合模式。在我们第一年的学习中，所有的教学都是线上进行的。所以，我其实不知道那种体验具体是怎样的，因为我以前从未当过临床心理学实习生，但我可以想象这与现在刚入学、全员都能线下聚在一起的这一届学员有很大不同。
So we had to start that online um the placements that we had were mixed some people were in person some people were remote um I was mostly in person for my placements I did want that um I wanted some time out the house um I wanted some time to meet people um but I guess one of the things that came through from Covid is that there was ways that you could work from home if you needed to, if you or if you wanted to. So there has been aspects of my placements that have been at home which I think has brought a different set of skills. I think our cohort has developed in a way that we had to respond to such a changing world, that we have a set of skills that is almost unique to people who started training in 2020, that we had to sort of very quickly move from just being in person to being online, to then sometimes being in person,
所以我们不得不以线上方式开始。我们参加的实习也是混合的，有些人是线下的，有些人是远程的。我的实习大部分是线下的，我是希望这样的——我想要一些离开家的外出的时间，我想要有一些与人面对面交流的时间。不过，从新冠疫情中显现出来的一点是，如果需要的话，或者如果你愿意的话，确实有很多在家办公的方式。因此，我的实习中确实也有一些居家办公的环节，我认为这培养了另一套技能。我觉得我们这一届学员在应对这样一个瞬息万变的世界时，发展出了一种几乎是 2020 年开始培训的人所独有的技能——我们不得不非常迅速地从纯线下转为线上，然后再在 Sometimes 线下、Sometimes 线上之间切换，对变化做出相当迅速的反应。所以，确实是一段非常不同、非常独特的经历。
sometimes being online, responding quite quickly to change um so yeah quite quite a different experience quite different indeed and you know um given that this was 2020 March 2020 and we've all been navigating online we should have had a better experience today with my mic shouldn't we I should have been able to sort it out by now but yeah for those of you not party to to the frustration that poor Victoria's had trying to put up with me trying to sort out my airpods um yeah it's a bit embarrassing but yeah you know when it's clients it's it's tricky isn't it like trying to to help them get online how to help yourself get online and trying to make sure the sound quality is good enough and the the internet connectivity and all of that jazz it's it's a big deal and it's a lot it's a lot
确实很独特。而且你知道，鉴于那是 2020 年 3 月，我们当时都在网上摸索，今天我的麦克风本该有更好的表现才对，我早该把它弄好的，对吧？但对于那些未能体会到可怜的维多利亚不得不忍耐我调试 AirPods 的挫败感的人来说，呃，这确实有点尴尬。不过你知道的，当面对来访者时，情况往往很棘手，不是吗？比如试图帮助他们上线，如何帮助自己上线，还要确保音质足够好、网络连接顺畅等等，这些都是大事，而且涉及大量的
of change a lot to juggle um somebody messaged me recently on my socials i think it was even in the last week and asked about the doctorate in clinical psychology and said is it is it online only or is it taught in person and i said actually it actually, I don't know of any courses that are doing online only as a provision. And I said, I would have some concerns about it being an online only provision because it feels like there's lots of important things to learn about being in a team when you're actually in a team and about being in a room with service users and families
变动和需要平衡的事物。最近有人在我的社交媒体上给我发私信——好像就在过去的一周内——询问关于临床心理学博士项目的事情，问它是纯线上授课，还是线下授课。我说：“事实上，据我所知，没有任何课程是纯线上授课的。”我还说：“如果纯粹依靠线上授课，我会有所担忧，因为在实际团队中学习如何融入团队，以及与服务使用者、不同年龄段的家庭以及你的督导共处一室，有许多非常重要的东西需要去学习。”不过，当我给出这个回答时，我并没有真正考虑到这对你们这一届以及你们下一届学员所产生的影响。毕竟你们经历了一个线上与线下相结合的混合过程。你有什么看法？博士项目可以作为纯线上学位来教授吗？
and people of different ages and also your supervisor. But I guess when I gave that answer, I hadn't really considered the impact on your cohort and probably the cohort after you. Having been through quite a mixed bag of online and in person. What's your thoughts? Could the doctorate be taught as an online only qualification? That's a really good question. And yeah, I've got a few thoughts about it. I would think in theory, yes, as our cohort had all of our teaching online in the first year, we were very much assured that the quality of the teaching would be the same and there was a lot of benefits to having it online. Obviously the world outside was very unsafe at that period of time and speaking of someone with a long-term
这是一个非常好的问题。是的，对此我有一些看法。从理论上讲，是的，因为我们这一届在第一年的所有教学都在线上，当时我们被极大地保证教学质量会是一样的，而且线上教学有很多好处。显然，当时外部世界很不安全，作为一个有长期健康状况的人，我很清楚这一点，我属于易感人群。尽管如此，我仍然选择去某些实习点进行线下实习，不过做好了充分的个人防护装备（PPE）和风险评估。然而，我知道对某些人来说这根本不是一个选项。所以据我所知，大约一年或更久前，曾有过不少讨论，关于课程是否应该在网课设置上提供更多灵活性。而且我认为，一旦事情开始稳定下来，许多课程又完全恢复了线下，失去了一些在线上提供方面的灵活性，这确实对有健康状况的人、神经多样性人群以及肩负照料责任的人产生了影响。所以，我认为这是行得通的。
health condition, I was very aware of that, I was on the vulnerable list um i still chose to go in person to some of my placements but with a lot of you know ppe and risk assessment in place um however i know for some people that would that would not have been an option at all um so i know there was quite a bit of discussion maybe a year or so ago about um courses maybe having a bit more flexibility about their online provision and as i think once things started to settle down, a lot of courses went back to completely in person and lost a bit of their flexibility in having an online offer, which I think does impact people with health conditions, neurodivergent people, people with caring responsibilities. So I think it can be done.
这里关键在于灵活性和选择权，从而找到对人们最有效的方式。我们在日常工作中也会这样做。我们会做出调整，我们会与雇主沟通关于灵活工作安排的事宜，我们可能会有混合办公的安排。所以我的内心深处认为，博士项目或许也可以保留一些这种灵活性，为那些可能需要的人提供这些选项，
I think there's something there about flexibility and choice about what works best for people. We do that in our day-to-day jobs. We make adjustments. We speak to employers about things that we might have flexible working arrangements. We might have hybrid working arrangements. So there's a part of me that thinks that maybe the doctorate could also keep some of that flexibility as well and have that as options um for people who may who
以便有需要的人能够选择。所以这或许只是一个“让我们拭目以待未来会发生什么”的问题。是的，也许吧。正如我认为的那样，自疫情以来，我们显然成功地真正提升了技术水平。虽然有时会出现小故障，但我们确实拥有了这些选择，不是吗？所以你看，我们现在正在这样做，我们正在线上进行。我最近的一次实习是在一个员工心理服务部门，那是一个覆盖整个信托基金的服务机构，几乎 100% 在线提供服务。是的，有些同事会到办公室来，但因为在一个大型信托基金和一个广阔的地理区域内，这是一个小团队，所以它主要在线提供，以增加获取服务的途径。因此，我认为我们在临床世界中采用的方法，同样也可以应用
may need it so it might just be a case of let's see what the future brings yeah yeah maybe um as I think from Covid we've obviously managed to really up our technical provision and yes there's hiccups sometimes um but we do have those options don't we so you know we're doing this now we're doing this online um one of the placements the most recent placement that I I had, was in an employee psychology service and that was a trust-wide service and provided nearly 100% online. Yes, there was some colleagues that would come in, but because it was a small team in a large trust and a large geographical area, it was offered primarily online to increase access um so i think that the things that we are adopting in our clinical world we can also put in place
到培训领域中去。好的，是的，比如把人们当作独立的个体来对待，而且是生活在 2023 年的现代化个体。你知道，一般来说我们拥有合适的技术，大多数人已经学会了使用“随时就诊”（Attend Anywhere）、Zoom、Teams 或类似的软件。而且，是的，我想我们要确保——这正是包容性论点的一部分吧？——即平权提升对这个专业的准入，并确保人们能够以适合他们的方式展现自我。我知道在为本期节目做准备而通过 LinkedIn 与你交流时，你提到在培训的最后一年里，你自己也经历了一些相当大的变动。你想跟我们简单聊聊这个吗？
in the training world too okay yeah like treat people as individuals and modern individuals at that that are operating in 2023 you know we've got generally speaking the right technology most people have navigated you know attend anywhere or zoom or teams or something like that and yeah i guess let's make sure that i guess it's some of that that inclusivity argument isn't it around leveling the access to the profession and making sure that people can show up in a way that works for them and I know from speaking with you via LinkedIn in preparation for this that you had some quite big changes yourself during certainly the last year of training did you want to tell us a little bit about that?
当然可以。我进入培训时就带有一种既有的健康状况，叫做溃疡性结肠炎，属于克罗恩病家族。对于不了解的人来说，这是一种肠道疾病，无法治愈，它对我产生的影响因人而异，轻则只是一些胃肠道不适，重则需要住院治疗。所以它对我的影响程度差异很大。也有处于缓解期的阶段，但我还没有幸运到能达到临床缓解的程度。它总是处于一种“还行、勉强可以”的状态，或者是恶化状态，并不总是在一个真正非常好的状态。所以在培训之前我就知道这一点，并且与课程工作人员以及直线经理进行了所有必要的讨论，以便在课程和实习中落实合理的调整。
Yeah sure, so I came into training with a pre-existing health condition, it's called ulcerative colitis, it's in the Crohn's family, people that don't know, it's a disease of the gut, it's not curable and it can really vary in terms of how it impacts me from just a bit of sort of gastrointestinal discomfort all the way through to hospitalisation. So it can really vary on how on how it impacts things. There's also periods where I'm in remission, but I have not been lucky enough yet to get to a clinical remission. It's just always sort of been at an OK, an okay-ish place or it's gone bad, it's not necessarily been in a really really good place. So I knew that prior to training and had all the discussions required with the course staff and with the line manager to put in place things like reasonable
然而，一个打乱计划的意外插曲发生在我的研究项目期间。在最后一年里，你要致力于你的大型研究项目，这希望是你真正热衷的课题，你要全身心投入两年半的时间。我做的主题是探讨焦虑女性的自杀倾向、自闭症特征和伪装行为。说实话，在这个过程中，我开始在其中看到了一点自己的影子。这个课题的灵感来源于我在培训前和培训期间的临床实践。当我深入研究自闭症、自闭症女性以及伪装行为时，我开始看到自己身上的一些部分——这些部分我以前虽然隐约认得出，但并没有把它们联系起来。这随后促使我申请了自闭症评估，并在今年 3 月被确诊为自闭症。那时我正处于撰写毕业论文的水深火热之中。
adjustments on the course and on placements. However, something that threw a bit of a spanner in the works was when I was doing my research project. So in your final year you work towards your large-scale research project which is hopefully something that you're really passionate about, you completely delve into it for two and a half years. And I did mine on exploring suicidality, autistic traits and camouflaging within women with anxiety. And I began to see a bit of myself in it, if I'm honest. It had been inspired by my clinical practice prior to training and during training. As I delved into the research into autism, into autistic women, into camouflaging, I began to see parts of myself that I had recognised but hadn't made those links and that then led me to request an autism assessment which then was confirmed that I am autistic in March this year so when I was right in the throes of writing up my
所以这真的是一个非常重大的……嗯，用“重磅炸弹”可能不太合适，因为我显然想过这是一种可能性，否则我也不会去申请评估。但它仍然是一件大大震动了我的世界的事情，因为我随后开始质疑关于自己如何走到这一步的几乎所有事情：我是不是伪装自己才混到这里的？许多极度自我贬低的疑问开始涌现，而与此同时，我还在努力撰写一篇基本上能决定我未来的论文。所以那段经历相当具有挑战性。但正如我所说，在那次诊断大约六个月后，我非常高兴自己去做了评估，我现在对它的心态好多了。我把它看作是一件
thesis so that was a really big I wouldn't well bombshell maybe isn't the right word because I'd obviously thought it could be a possibility or I wouldn't have gone for the assessment but it still was something that shook my world quite a bit as I then started to question pretty much everything about how I had even got to this position had I faked my way here lots of really self-deprecating questions started to happen all while I was trying to write a thesis that could determine my future essentially so that was quite challenging but as I say sort of six months after that diagnosis I'm really glad that I did do it and I'm in a much better place with it now. I see it as something that's
实际上对我有所帮助的事情。它帮我指出了问题所在，帮我在需要时做到绝对的诚实。它还帮助我在我工作过的地方与服务使用者产生共鸣——我经常接触到一些往往被严重误解的年轻女性，我们会建立起良好的关系和连结。当我开始研究关于类似神经类型的个体是如何建立连结的文献时，我开始把它看作一种优势：虽然它伴随着困难，但其中绝对也蕴含着巨大的力量。天哪，你经历了一段多么不寻常的旅程啊！我有太多问题想问你了。但仅就我们听众自身的知识储备而言，成人评估和诊断的流程简而言之是怎样的？我们是在谈论来自全科医生（GP）的转诊吗？
actually helped me. It's helped me to call things out. It's helped me to be brutally honest when needed. It's helped me to empathise with service users in places that I've worked where often it was young women who were quite misunderstood that I would work with and we'd develop a good rapport we'd develop a good connection and then once I've started to look into the literature about how people with similar neurotypes do make connections it's then made me see it as a as a strength that has difficulties but there's absolutely strengths within it too. Gosh what a journey you've been on and there's so many questions I want to ask you but just in terms of our listeners own knowledge base how does adult assessment and diagnosis work in a nutshell? Are we talking, you know, a referral from the GP?
具体是怎么运作的？我的情况可能有点不太一样。我当时听说了所有关于漫长等待名单的恐怖故事，我心里有一部分只是想在毕业和获得资格前把这件事情搞清楚、做完。所以我通过一位曾在该课程上讲过课的心理学家联系了一家私立机构。我给他打了电话，我们进行了初步的电话咨询。他对我说的是，他认为评估会有所帮助，但他
What are we talking about exactly here? So I did things maybe a little bit differently. So I had heard all the horror stories about the waiting lists and there was a part of me that just wanted to get this known, get this done before I finished and before I qualified. So I rang a private service through a psychologist who had actually done some teaching on the course. I rang him and we had an initial phone consultation. And what he said to me was that he wouldn't he thought an assessment would be helpful, but that he wasn't prepared
不愿意收我的钱，因为作为一名 NHS（国民保健制度）员工，我有权通过我的直线经理转诊进行评估。于是我就这么做了。我联系了直线经理——向她表明“我觉得我可能是自闭症，你能帮我转诊进行评估吗”其实是有点吓人的——但我确实去做了，并通过直线经理被转诊到了当地的服务机构。几个月后我收到了预约通知。去到那里之后，基本上有人对我说，作为一个临床心理学实习生，我对评估流程了解得太多了，所以标准化测试对我不大适用。因此，评估更多是通过对我本人以及我姐姐的访谈来进行的，同时对照了 DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）中列出的一些症状。所以这更多是一个访谈的过程。我想这与标准的评估有很大不同。总共进行了大约四个小时的长谈和艰难对话，最后在我的最后一次预约中得出结论：是的，根据我们掌握的信息，我们可以做出诊断。
to take my money because as an NHS employee, I was entitled through my line manager to be referred for an assessment so I did that I approached my line manager which was a little bit scary um to approach my my line manager to say oh I think I might be autistic can you refer me for an assessment please um but I did do it and I was referred to the local service through my line manager. That took a few months to get an appointment through. And then once I had that appointment, I basically got told that as someone who's a trainee clinical psychologist, I would know too much about the assessment process. So the standardized tests wouldn't really apply to me. So it was more done through an interview myself and an interview with my sister
好的，谢谢你澄清这一点。听起来这更像是一种职业健康（occupational health）性质的转诊，而不是常规的来自全科医生的 NHS 医疗转诊。是的，这是通过当地的自闭症服务机构进行的，但因为是通过直线经理进行的，所以更偏向于那种……是的，是的。谢谢你解开这个谜团。对于任何在收听的听众来说，可能会好奇“伪装”（camouflaging）、“面具”（masking）是什么意思？你能为我们稍微解读一下吗？
and looking through some of the symptoms that are listed in the DSM. So it was more done as an interview process. So quite different, I think, to what a standard assessment would be. It was about four hours in total of having long and difficult conversations to then come to in my final appointment to say yes, we can make that diagnosis based on the information that we have. Okay, thank you for clarifyingifying that so it sounds like that was an occupational health kind of referral rather than necessarily a medical nhs referral from your gp
当然可以。伪装被定义为神经多样性人群采用神经典型人群（也就是非自闭症人群）的特质来融入他们世界的一种方式。当我们谈论“戴面具”（masking）时，可能是指在很小的时候，尤其是神经多样性的女性，她们会模仿其他人的神态、面部表情和小动作来进行社交，以帮助自己度过难关。因为她们会非常非常仔细地观察其他人之间的互动，看什么行得通，什么行不通，并以此为基础基本上构建起她们的社交圈。所以她们可能不一定觉得自己在情感上真正连结到了这个
yeah so it was done with the local autism service but because done through line management it was it was more of a yeah yeah yeah thank you for illuminating that. And then anybody else who might be listening might be like camouflage, masking. What does that mean? Could you guide us through that a little bit? Yeah, of course. So camouflaging has been coined as a way of neurodivergent people taking on traits from neurotypical people, so as in people who aren't autistic, to fit into their world essentially. So when we talk about masking, it might be that at a young age, especially, especially neurodivergent women, they will take on the mannerisms, the facial expressions, the social chatter to get them through because they will observe very very closely the interactions that other people are having, see what goes okay, see what doesn't and start to build around their social circle essentially so they might not feel necessarily connected to this
社交圈，但因为她们已经被同化了——基本上就是她们观察得足够多，吸收了足够多的那些神态和社交礼仪，从而能够融入其中，不引人注目。她们看起来表现得还不错，因为她们会恰当地微笑，能保持适度的眼神交流，表达也可能相当流畅。（我知道有时我表达得不够流畅，不过我现在是在“卸下面具”状态下说话。）这就是为什么很多自闭症女性直到晚年才被识别出来的原因，因为她们为了生存，已经发展出了那种社交面具、社交伪装。但问题是，这样做需要付出极高的代价，因为一个人要时刻关注别人在做什么、
social circle but because they've assimilated so essentially they have observed enough they've taken on enough of those mannerisms of those social niceties that they fit in they go under the radar they seem like they're doing okay because they smile appropriately they'll give you an all right level of eye contact they might come across as quite articulate i know i sometimes don't but i'm unmasking at the moment um but that's why a lot of um autistic women don't get recognized until later in life because they have developed that that social masking that social camouflage and to get to get through but the problem is is that there's such a high cost to that because that's such a huge cognitive load on somebody to be constantly looking at what other
质问自己“我的眼神交流是不是太多了？哦，我大概应该把视线移开了，因为我注意到某某人在说完两句话后就把视线移开了”，这需要承担巨大的认知负荷。你无时无刻不在这样做，这带来了极高的认知和情感负担。因此，通常会发生的情况是，一旦社交场合结束、社交期望降低，就会发生崩溃、精疲力竭（burnout），然后一个人静静地坐着。对我来说，我会坐着摇晃身体——这是我以前并没有真正意识到的一种行为，是我试图在社交场合结束后让自己平静下来的方式。我会独自坐在绝对的安静中，只是不停地摇晃，这可能会持续好几个小时。但因为这些是被隐藏起来的，没有人看到，也没有人觉得这是个问题。
people are doing questioning yourself am I giving too much eye contact? Oh, I should probably look away now because I've noticed that person X looks away after they've said two sentences. You're doing that all the time and that has such a high cognitive and emotional load. So then what will often happen is once that social situation is over, the social expectation is low, crash, burnout, sitting quietly. For me, I sit and rock, something that I hadn't really recognised as something that was me just trying to regulate after a social situation, that I would just sit in complete silence by myself and just rock and this could be for hours but because that was hidden no one saw that and no one saw that that was a problem but because
由于我第二天去学校时依然和大家说话，而且我算得上比较聪明的（虽不是最聪明的，但也算聪明），所以我能够滑过雷达，不被察觉。我觉得对我而言，我的伪装和戴面具的行为也得到了我作为表演艺术学生的经历的支持或助长。我是一个害羞的孩子——无论当时被称为害羞还是内向——学校也发现了这一点，发现我很害羞，更喜欢一个人坐着看书。于是我父母出于最好的愿望，把我送去了一所表演学校。我其实很喜欢那里，我真的很享受。我基本上学会了“如何做一个人的剧本”——这听起来可能有点戏剧化，但本质上我确实是这么做的。因为我阅读了那么多的剧本，唱了不同的歌曲，开始了解各种情况以及在
I'd then go to school the next day and talk to people and I was reasonably bright I wasn't the brightest but I was reasonably bright so I could slip under the radar. I think for me as well my camouflaging and masking was supported slash promoted through being a performing arts student. I was a shy child, shy introverted however however it was called at the time and it had been spotted it had been spotted by school that I was shy that I preferred to sit by myself and read a book and so my my parents in you know with the best intentions sent me to a stage school um which I loved I really enjoyed it um I essentially learned the script on how to be a person which sounds a bit melodramatic but essentially I did because I got to read so many scripts sing different songs start to learn about situations and how in the
剧本中如果有人悲伤，人们会如何反应，而其他人又会如何回应这种反应。所以现在回想起来，这绝对促成了我发展出面具和伪装。谢谢，这真的非常具有启发性，而且听上去也相当痛苦。当你摇晃身体时，你觉得痛苦吗？还是觉得具有抚慰作用？一开始可能会觉得痛苦，因为我认为那是情绪最高涨的时候。我从学校度过一天回来——或者现在来说，是工作日或大学里度过充满社交负担的一天回来——身体会处于一种高度亢奋的状态。但当我开始摇晃、试图
script people would respond if someone was sad this is how someone could respond and then that's how other people would respond to that person's response so when I think about it now it definitely contributed to me developing developing my masking developing my camouflage. Thank you that's really really illuminating and also a point sounds quite distressing did it feel distressing when you're rocking or did it feel soothing? Initially it would feel distressing because I think that was when the emotion was the highest so I would come home from a day at school or it could you know nowadays it would be a day at work a day at uni if there's been a lot of social load and it would feel quite distressing the sort of my body would be in quite a heightened state but as I would start to to rock try and
让自己平静下来时，这就是我在调节自我，把我带回到能够重新参与活动或重新融入家庭生活、社交生活以及所有那些被期望去应对的事情的状态中。所以，摇晃身体本身并不让人觉得痛苦，那绝对是我试图让自己平静下来的过程。只不过刚开始的时候，情绪通常会非常非常高涨。太棒了，谢谢。那么在培训期间或与临床群体接触时，这又是如何体现出来的呢？甚至在确诊之后，这在你所做的临床工作中是如何表现的？
that would be me regulating that would be me bringing myself back down to then re-engage in activity or re-engage in family family life and social life all of those sorts of things um that were kind of expected to get on with. But yeah, so it didn't feel distressing to rock. It was definitely me trying to regulate myself. But the emotion would usually be quite, quite high when I would start. Great, thank you. And how has this cropped up for you during training or with clinical groups? maybe even since diagnosis how does this play out for you within the clinical work you do? Yeah I guess for me I've got a bit of an eye for neurodivergence which I didn't necessarily know why I had this eye for it or interest in looking for
是的，我想对我来说，我对神经多样性有一种特殊的直觉或敏锐度。在确诊之前，我并不一定知道自己为什么会有这种敏锐度或去寻找神经多样性的兴趣。我发现自己会被那些在医疗服务中可能没有得到很好对待的人吸引，并开始提出疑问：“难道我们没有考虑过自闭症吗？难道我们没有考虑过多动症吗？”并开始提出这些问题。我当时不一定有答案，但我只是觉得有必要提出问题。另外，我觉得自己有很强的正义感，我认为这极大地影响了我的临床工作。我知道有些心理学家有时会从社会正义工作中稍微退一步，他们这样做绝对有充分的合规理由。但对我来说，当我看到世上有不公现象时，我就会觉得我必须
neurodivergence before getting the diagnosis, I would find myself sort of drawn to people that maybe weren't treated that well in services and start to ask questions and think, well, have we not thought about autism? Have we not about ADHD have we and start to ask those those questions I didn't necessarily have the answer but I just felt a need to ask questions I think as well I've got quite a strong sense of justice and I think that's something that has massively influenced my clinical work I'm I know quite a few psychologists can sometimes step back a little bit from social justice work and they will have absolutely valid reasons for doing so but for me it feels that when I see injustice in the world I feel like I have to
做点什么，我必须了解更多，我必须发声，我必须倾听那些比我懂得更多、正在发声的人。我真的感觉自己沉浸在了那些世界中。在神经多样性的世界里，我们谈论“过度专注”（hyper-focus），这绝对是我在助理岗位和培训期间的一大优势。一旦我专注于某件事，我就会全神贯注并把它做好。我一直因为组织能力强而受到赞扬，以前也有人问过我：“你怎么这么有组织性？你是怎么做到的？”甚至有人让我和别人分享我的日程表，把它作为日程表应该长什么样的光辉典范。对我来说，这只是第二本能。我无法想象哪一个工作日我的日程表里没有非常清晰的格子，标明我几点在做什么、这需要花多长时间。我不喜欢模糊不清、开放式的日程表。
do something about it, I have to learn more, I have to say something, I have to listen to people who know more than me who are saying something. I do feel like I really immerse myself in those worlds. In the neurodivergent world we talk about hyper focus and that's something that has absolutely been a strength for me through my assistant roles, through training, that once I'm on something, I will focus and I will get it done. I've always been praised for being really organised and have been asked before, how are you so organised? What do you do? I've been asked to share my calendars with people as a glowing example of what a calendar should look like and for me that's just second nature. I can't think of a work day where I'm not putting slots in my calendar that are very clear that this is what I'm doing here and this is how long it's going to take. I don't like having a vague open calendar.
我喜欢把事情安排得井井有条，即使工作本身并不是井然有序的——比如我在住院病房工作时，工作本身并不井然有序，可能会相当不可预测——但我会利用日程表来组织我的时间。这经常是人们特别注意到的地方。我想我所有的实习督导都在他们的报告中某个地方提到过我是如何做到极具条理、总是准备充分的。但这只是我的第二天能，我甚至不需要去思考它。所以，如果人们想要了解更多关于这类方法的信息，我想这就类似于工作规划（job planning）和时间块划分（time blocking）。如果你觉得一切都有点一团糟，正是这些方法能够帮助你为混乱带来一些秩序。维多利亚，你是这个意思吗？
I like to have things very organised and very ordered even if the work itself isn't ordered as I've worked on inpatient wards for instance where the work isn't ordered it can be quite unpredictable but I use my calendar to organise my time and that's often been something that people have really picked up on I think all of my placement supervisors have put something somewhere in my report about how I'm very organised I'm always very well prepared but that's just something that is second nature to me, I don't have to think about. So if people wanted to learn more about those sort of approaches I think it's like job planning and time blockings, if you find everything feeling a bit squally it's those
是的，基本上就是这样。我过去共事过的经理也说过，在管理日程方面我其实不需要太多的工作规划或支持，因为我一直都能自己搞定。当然，我也理解有些人会觉得这真的非常、非常困难。我会在力所能及的范围内提供帮助，比如朋友或家人在整理事情遇到困难时，我都会尽力帮忙。但我有时觉得这意味着我干脆直接替他们把活儿干了，因为要把我脑子里发生的事情解释清楚有时实在太难了。
kinds of approaches that can help try and give some order to the chaos is that what you mean victoria yeah essentially and it's something that um managers that i've worked with in the past have said that you don't really need too much job planning or support with um managing your diary because i've always just been able to do it um which you know I understand that some people find it really, really difficult. And I try and help where I can. I really try and help, you know, friends, family, for instance, if they're struggling with organising things, I try my best. But I think sometimes that means I just jump in and do it for them. Because it's quite hard to explain what's going on in my brain sometimes.
是的，我懂的。从想要帮助他人和支持其他人的角度来看，这是否可以说唤起了你内心的一种渴望——希望看到更多人在这个专业中获得代表性？绝对是的。我是在从戏剧和表演艺术路线转行后进入临床心理学领域的。经过深思熟虑和生活中的一些变故，我稍晚一些时候将临床心理学选为转型路线。当时我确诊了健康状况，那正是我刚开始在 NHS 担任助理心理学家的一份全新工作大约一周的时候。我当时想：“就是这个了，我已经走上了这条正轨。”结果就在入职一周后，我因为这个一直隐瞒了五周的“神秘疾病”而住院了。我之前一直想着：没关系，它会过去的，我会好起来的，不要告诉任何人，不要小题大做，如果你做什么的话就会毁了这份工作的。但后来病情变得如此严重，以至于我住了院，在经历了一段相当可怕的住院生活后，我被诊断出了溃疡性结肠炎。在那一刻，我开始担心：
Yeah, okay, I hear you. And in terms of wanting to help others and wanting to support others is it fair to say this has sort of evoked something within you for wanting to to see people represented in the profession? Absolutely I sort of came into clinical psychology after switching from doing the drama and performing arts route and I switched to clinical psychology as a route a little bit later on after a lot of thought and a few things happening in my life. And then when I got my diagnosis of my health condition, it was about a week into a brand new job where I just started in the NHS and assistant psychologist I was like this is it I'm on the path and then I was hospitalized a week into the role with this mystery illness that I had been sitting on for five weeks thinking it's fine it'll go it'll go I'll be all right don't tell anybody don't make a fuss you're going to ruin this job if you do anything but then it got so serious that I was hospitalized and then I got the diagnosis of ulcerative colitis after a pretty horrendous hospital stay but then I started to worry at that
如果我的余生都要进出医院，我怎么可能成为一名临床心理学家呢？我感到心碎，因为我才刚开始一份崭新的工作，而且我非常担心在请了一段时间病假后如何重返工作岗位。我回去得太早了——在住院之后，因为我太害怕别人会怎么看待我产生的影响了。大家会不会觉得：“哦，她才来了一周就已经请假不干了”？然而我回去得实在是太早太早了，当时我身上还有很多身体上的疼痛，真的非常不舒服。但我还是回去了，结果很快又被劝说回去休假。不过我想，那种恐惧感深深地烙印在我心里：这个职业真的适合我吗？
point well how on earth can I be a clinical psychologist if I'm going to be in and out of hospital for the rest of my life and I was devastated that I just started a brand new job and I was so worried to go back to work after that period of sick I went back way too early after being in hospital because I was just so scared of the consequences of how I was going to be seen was it going to be like oh she's just been here a week and she's already been she's already off um whereas I went back way way way too early I was still in a lot of physical pain really not well at all but I did go back and then very quickly encouraged to go back off again but that I think that was something that that fear just sort of sat within me that is this the profession for me
我在这里会安全吗？我真的能完成我心里设想的所有事情吗？我们很容易对“有志路线”感到过分执着，比如：“我要做这个助理心理学家职位，我要做多久，然后我要跳槽，然后我要申请博士项目，事情接下来会这样这样发展……”我们会把未来的路线图死板地规划好。当时我吓坏了，因为我脑子里那个相当死板的关于未来发展的计划可能无法实现了。谢天谢地，在那份工作中，我得到了极好的支持，职业健康部门棒极了，合理的调整在眨眼间就落实到位了，我的督导老实说也是最棒的督导，我在那个角色中真的非常、非常茁壮地成长了。随后我转换了
am I going to be safe here am I going to actually be able to do all the things that I'd set in my mind that I was going to do? We can get very fixed I think on the aspiring route of that well I'm going to do this AP position, I'm going to do it for this long and then I'm going to move on and then I'm going to apply for the doctorate and then this is how it's all going to go and we sort of map it out about how it's going to happen and I was terrified that this plan that I had quite rigidly in my head of what was going to happen wasn't going to happen. Thankfully in that job I was so well supported, occupational health were fantastic, reasonable adjustments were put in at a blink of an eye and my supervisor was honestly the most wonderful supervisor and I really really flourished in that role. I then moved
角色——就像助理们常做的那样。为了在别处获得更多经验，我换了一个岗位，结果却有了一次糟糕的经历。所以，是的，换到一个没有得到那么好支持的不同岗位上，又重新引发了那个循环：“我是不是应该放弃这个职业？我能做到吗？”在那份工作中存在霸凌现象，不仅针对我，也针对其他人。那不是一个友好的环境，而不幸的是，我们在 NHS 中过于频繁地听到这种团队中确实发生霸凌的情况。所以那次经历并不理想，我也确实遭受了基于我残疾的歧视。
roles as assistants do. I moved role to get some more experience elsewhere and had a terrible experience. So, yeah, moving into a different a different role where I wasn't supported as well. That then started the cycle all over again of should I just drop this career? Can I do this? There was there was bullying in that role not just for me but for other people it was not it was not a friendly environment and unfortunately we do hear that all too often in the NHS that there are those teams where where bullying does happen so it was not ideal for that to happen I did experience discrimination based on my disability
像助理那样。我换了岗位去其他地方积累经验，结果却有一段糟糕的经历。所以，是的，换到一个不那么受支持的新岗位，又开始了一个循环：我是不是该放弃这个职业？我能胜任吗？那个岗位上存在霸凌，不仅针对我，也针对其他人，那里的环境一点也不友好。不幸的是，我们在国民保健署（NHS）经常听到这种事，有些团队确实存在霸凌现象，所以发生这种情况很不理想，我确实经历过基于我的残疾的歧视。
quite publicly which again made me think how on earth can I do this? What if I get sent on a placement when I get on the course and they don't manage it very well? What can I do? I felt safe telling particular people about my diagnosis for them to be used against me was heartbreaking. So then I moved jobs again and again was really well supported. So it can really, really influence how your experience goes on how well you're supported when you do have a health condition. So I knew from my bad experience that this wasn't okay and I did take things further with it. There was relevant actions completed, but I thought this can't happen again.
完全公开地进行，这再次让我觉得我怎么可能做到这一点？如果我在课程开始后被派去实习，而他们处理得不好怎么办？我能做什么？我告诉特定的人我的诊断结果是安全的，但它们却被用来对付我，这让我心碎。所以后来我又不断换工作，每一次都得到了很好的支持。因此，当你确实有健康状况时，得到多好的支持真的会极大地影响你的经历。所以从我不好的经历中我知道这不正常，我确实对此采取了进一步的行动。采取了相关的行动，但我心想这不能再发生了。
This shouldn't happen again. Because one of the big things that I had experienced in that role was as an assistant, I had very little protection. My clinical work was very protected, but my emotional protection, I didn't have any standing as a band four assistant psychologist. I felt very exposed and very, very vulnerable. So that made me get onto, I guess, a social justice sort of movement that I had in my head. When I get onto training, this won't happen again. again quite a big idea but it has to go from
这不应该再发生了。因为我在那个职位上经历过的一大问题是，作为一名助理，我的保护非常少。我的临床工作受到了很好的保护，但我的情感保护，我作为四级助理心理学家没有任何地位。我感到非常无助和非常非常脆弱。所以这让我开始关注我脑海中的一种社会正义运动。当我开始培训时，这不会再次发生。这又是一个很大的想法，但它必须从
somewhere doesn't it so when I started training that's when I wanted to start to influence things to make things different to start being more open about my health condition and hopefully help others to do that as well so then that's when the ball started rolling with the work that I ended up doing. Thank you for guiding us through that and I'm so sorry to hear what you experienced but I think you so nicely encapsulated there that sometimes people will be well aligned and well you know well placed to support us well and to support us optimally and sometimes through no fault of our own people won't be but it's not always that the answer for why that's problematic lays within ourselves sometimes it's just systemic and actually we can we can just respond to that by by taking ourselves and moving ourselves elsewhere and knowing that it's not us that's the problem.
某个地方开始，对吧？所以当我开始培训时，那就是我想开始产生影响的时候，让事情变得不同，开始对我的健康状况更加开放，并希望帮助其他人也这样做。于是，我最终所做的工作的雪球就这样滚起来了。谢谢你引导我们了解这些，听到你的经历我感到非常抱歉，但我认为你很好地总结了这一点，有时人们会很好地保持一致，你知道，处于很好的位置来很好地支持我们，并以最佳方式支持我们；有时并非我们的过错，人们做不到这一点，但导致这一问题的原因并不总是在我们自己身上，有时它只是系统性的，实际上我们可以通过离开并将自己转移到别的地方来对此做出反应，并且知道问题不在于我们。
It's an organization or it's a cultural setup in an organization. So I would really urge our listeners to feel like if they feel like they are a square peg in a round hole or a round peg in a square hole, to think about actually maybe, you know not pathologizing yourself is the problem maybe it's maybe it's a service maybe it's the culture um and you know you might well find that you're really really happy elsewhere absolutely um the the jobs that I've had where it has gone well I've been encouraged to flourish and use my strengths and when things have been more difficult take the time to rest because then I'll be even better once I've had that rest to try and prevent that burnout to try and prevent the fatigue that comes with my
这是一个组织的问题，或者是组织中的一种文化设置。因此，我强烈敦促我们的听众，如果他们觉得自己是方孔中的圆钉，或者是圆孔中的方钉，要考虑实际上也许，你知道，不要把你自己病理化当作问题所在，也许是服务的问题，也许是文化的问题，嗯，你知道，你很可能会发现自己在其他地方真的非常非常快乐。绝对的，嗯，我经历过的那些进展顺利的工作中，我一直被鼓励去蓬勃发展并发挥我的优势；而当事情更具挑战性时，花时间休息，因为在我休息之后，我会表现得更好，以尽量防止这种倦怠，尽量防止伴随着我的
condition it's it's they're easy things to do and I think sometimes in the in some of the cultures that that we experience in in the NHS and in other roles that we forget that that some of the things that people need are quite straightforward but they can make such a huge difference to people and absolutely when things go go wrong we will we will blame ourselves we'll say there's something that I did it's to do with me I can't do this but you absolutely can um when you're in the right place and when you're well supported you can do you can do it um that's not to say there's not challenges along the way that absolutely have been um but in the roles I have had they've absolutely formed how I got onto the doctorate how I've got through training and how I've managed to pop out at the end um relatively unscathed.
状况而来的疲劳。这些都是很简单的事情，而且我认为有时在我们在NHS和其他角色中经历的一些文化中，我们忘记了人们需要的一些东西其实相当直接，但它们能给人们带来巨大的改变。绝对地，当事情出错时，我们会责怪自己，我们会说这是我做的事，这与我有关，我做不到这一点，但你绝对可以，当你身处正确的环境并且得到良好的支持时，你绝对可以做到，这并不是说这一路上没有挑战，绝对是有的；但在我担任过的职务中，它们绝对塑造了我如何进入博士学位课程、如何度过培训以及我如何最终相对无损地脱颖而出。
Thank you I think people are going to find it so um refreshing to hear you speak and so interesting and useful as well in terms of learning points just in case people aren't familiar with what ulcerative colitis is could you tell us a little bit about what that is do we know what causes it or is it autoimmune um just guide us through a little bit of that if that's okay yeah sure um so it's it is an autoimmune condition it's um a lifelong non-curable condition where the something has in the immune system decided to attack itself and where it forms that attack is in the large intestine that differs from Crohn's disease which usually more people have heard of which can impact anywhere from the esophagus all the way to the small intestine. So ulcerative colitis is localized to the large intestine.
谢谢你，我认为人们会觉得听你讲话非常清新、非常有趣，而且在学习要点方面也非常有用。为了防范人们不熟悉溃疡性结肠炎是什么，你能给我们简单介绍一下那是什么吗？我们知道是什么引起的吗？还是自身免疫性的？如果可以的话，请给我们简单介绍一下。好的，当然。所以它确实是一种自身免疫性疾病，它是一种终身无法治愈的疾病，免疫系统中的某些东西决定攻击自身，而它形成攻击的地方在大肠。这与克罗恩病不同，通常更多人听说过克罗恩病，它可以影响从食道一直到小肠的任何部位。因此，溃疡性结肠炎局限于大肠。
So what ends up happening is that as it's attacking itself, the lining of the intestine starts to ulcerate. That's where the ulcerative bit comes from. So you get ulcers, you get sores and you get abrasions essentially along along the intestine so the things that are in the gut to try and protect us um that they're not working as well there's not necessarily a known cause for it um there's there's a i think with most autoimmune conditions they say it's a mix of a sort of a genetic and an environmental trigger. However, when I was researching autism for myself, I found a really, really large link between ulcerative colitis and other gastrointestinal disorders and autism. So there's a part of me that has a little bit of a soapbox to stand on that maybe we should be screening for autism in the physical health sphere a little bit
所以最终发生的情况是，当它攻击自身时，肠道内壁开始溃疡。这就是“溃疡”这个词的由来。所以你会得到溃疡，你会本质上在肠道沿线出现疮和擦伤，因此肠道中试图保护我们的东西并没有发挥太好的作用。不一定有一个已知的病因，我想对于大多数自身免疫性疾病，他们会说它是某种遗传和环境触发因素的混合。然而，当我为自己研究自闭症时，我发现溃疡性结肠炎和其他胃肠道疾病与自闭症之间有着非常非常紧密的联系。所以我的内心有一部分有一种冲动，也许我们应该在身体健康领域稍微多做一点自闭症筛查
more as there is such a huge link between experiencing autoimmune conditions and neurodivergence? I've heard that as well and I think it's something around so what I've heard is that stress and trauma affects all of our muscles and our body and our systems and our structures and our gut has what's called smooth muscles in it striate muscles um and the way that um the way that stress and trauma um and trying to kind of manage our own internal systems work is that that will affect our striate muscles and one of the ways we can to kind of make sure that we're relaxing ourselves is to not clench our fists like this to sit and sort of relax and take a breath and that encourages all of our striate muscles to relax which is part of our gut and so I've definitely heard that link before because the theory is that people on the
因为经历自身免疫性疾病和神经发散性之间有这么大的联系？我也听说过这一点，我认为这与以下因素有关：我听说压力和创伤会影响我们所有的肌肉、身体、系统和结构，我们的肠道有所谓的平滑肌和横纹肌，压力和创伤以及试图管理我们自己的内部系统的方式会影响我们的横纹肌，我们放松自己的一种方式是不要像这样紧握拳头，而是坐下来放松并深呼吸，这会促使我们所有的横纹肌放松，这也是我们肠道的一部分，所以我绝对听说过这种联系，因为理论上认为处于
autistic spectrum would find situations more anxiety provoking and like you said would be doing more that masking so they might be highly distressed or trying to blend into a situation and someone else might not know what's going on but it's that it's that duck and the legs analogy isn't it you know it looks very serene, you know, your job plan, your meticulous calendar, but actually, there's a great deal of work going on in the background that people wouldn't be aware of. And that has an impact on the body as well as the mind. 100% Yeah. And I guess for me thinking about the body and mind links that I hadn't really known that much about before getting into into psychology it makes so much sense now though doesn't it when we experience anxiety we get a bad tummy and for me it's a little bit different because it's it's an autistic anxiety so there's
自闭症谱系上的人会发现情况更能引发焦虑，就像你所说的那样，会做更多的掩饰，所以他们可能会高度痛苦或试图融入某种情况，而其他人可能不知道发生了什么，但这就像那只鸭子和腿的比喻，对吧？你知道，它看起来非常平静，你知道你的工作计划，你一丝不苟的日历，但实际上，在背景中有很多别人不会意识到的工作正在进行。这对身体和心灵都有影响。百分之百，是的。我想对我来说，在进入心理学之前我真的没有对身心联系了解太多，但现在这太有意义了，不是吗？当我们经历焦虑时，我们会肚子疼，而对我来说有点不同，因为这是一种自闭症式的焦虑，所以
differences there in that it's it's not necessarily a pathologized anxiety it's that I'm trying to fit in a world that's not built for me but that still creates an anxiety response in the body and so when I get a poorly anxiety tummy unfortunately with ulcerative colitis that's quite it's quite different it's a bit different so there is sometimes a coexistence of ulcerative colitis and IBS for example so I may get quite similar IBS symptoms but alongside that when you have the ulcerative colitis symptoms although it is localized to the large intestine you can get ulcers on your eyes on your mouth and one of the most distressing things for me is when I get ulcers on my eyes because there's no hiding them people can see when I've got one of the ulcers
其中存在差异，即这不一定是病理化的焦虑，而是我试图融入一个并非为我建造的世界，但这仍然在身体中产生焦虑反应，所以当我胃疼得厉害时，不幸的是，溃疡性结肠炎的情况相当不同，它有点不同。因此，溃疡性结肠炎和肠易激综合征有时会共存，例如我可能会出现非常相似的肠易激综合征症状，但除此之外，当你患有溃疡性结肠炎症状时，尽管它局限于大肠，你的眼睛和口腔也可能会长溃疡，对我来说最痛苦的事情之一就是我的眼睛长溃疡，因为这无处可藏，当我的眼睛长了其中一个溃疡时，人们能看出来
on my eyes they're really uncomfortable one eye will get really really red and inflamed and it just makes me feel so self-conscious I feel like I can't look people in the face or in the eyes so I'm already thinking about eye contact as an autistic person but when I've got this swelling on my eye I'm thinking about it even more because I'm going they can tell I've got really swollen eye what they're going to think about me whereas in reality they're probably not thinking about it at all or they might notice it and be like oh I look sore and then not think about it ever again whereas I will think about it all day so the those are more visible symptoms even though it's technically a non-visible illness there will be some visible symptoms sometimes there's also things like
它们真的很不舒服，一只眼睛会变得非常非常红肿，这让我感到非常自我意识，我觉得我无法直视别人的面部或眼睛，所以作为一名自闭症患者，我已经在考虑眼神接触了，但当我眼睛肿胀时，我想得更多，因为我在想他们能看出我有红肿的眼睛，他们会对我有何看法，而实际上他们可能根本没有想过这个问题，或者他们可能会注意到并觉得“哦，看起来很疼”，然后就再也不会想它了，而我会一整天都在想这件事。因此，这些是更明显的症状，尽管它技术上是一种不可见的疾病，但有时也会有一些可见的症状，例如
fatigue joint pain that I can really struggle with which are the more non-visible symptoms and can be a bit more difficult to explain but again there's such there's such links isn't there I guess with neurodivergence that there will be fatiguing effects from masking from camouflaging so it all intertwines and gets gets very messy um but you know it's it's something that isn't neither of them are curable neither would I want them to be it's just something that I have to manage. Thank you again and I hadn't realized about the the eyes and that the you know the sores can um can crop up in other parts of the body. So thank you for sharing that with us. But it sounds really painful and very uncomfortable for a variety of reasons. But
我可能会很难对付的疲劳、关节痛，这些是更不可见的症状，可能有点难以解释，但同样，存在着这样的联系，不是吗？我想神经发散性也会带来来自掩饰和伪装的疲劳影响，所以这一切交织在一起变得非常混乱，但是你知道，这是一种两者都无法治愈的东西，我也不希望治愈它们，这只是我必须管理的事情。再次感谢你，我以前没有意识到眼睛和溃疡可以在身体的其他地方出现。所以感谢你与我们分享这一点。但听起来由于各种原因，它真的很痛苦，非常不舒服。但是
many people would really struggle to work at all with this condition, especially during a flare up. So, you know, real hats off to you for not only working, but working at an incredibly high level. And you're about to start a qualified role as well. Yeah so thank you I sometimes can't believe it myself and it's it's very strange as sometimes that when I speak to people and when I've hosted workshops when I've hosted webinars and things like that and talk about disability and the things that I've been through I get like that and talk about disability and the things that I've been through I get some really lovely comments and some really lovely feedback but oh my goodness the imposter syndrome comes in when that happens of that oh my gosh you're an
许多人会很难在这种情况下工作，特别是在病情发作期间。所以，真的向你脱帽致敬，你不仅在工作，而且在令人难以置信的高水平上工作。而且你也将开始担任合格的职位。是的，所以谢谢你，有时连我自己都不敢相信，有时候这非常奇怪，当我与人交谈时，当我举办工作坊、举办网络研讨会之类的事情并谈论残疾以及我所经历的事情时，我得到了非常可爱的评论和非常可爱的反馈，但是噢天哪，当这种情况发生时，冒牌者综合征就来了，噢天哪，你是一个
inspiration and that you've done so well and all of that and yeah I'm so pleased and I'm so privileged and I feel so honoured to have done the things that I've done at the same time it's not been it's not been easy and it's not been something that I necessarily feel inspirational for doing I just feel like I've managed to make a set of pretty rubbish circumstances and try and use my values and try and use who I am as a person to forge a career that I hope that as I'm more vocal about these things that we can change some of the things that keep that gatekeep the career um so yeah when I go into my next post I'll be working with older people in an inpatient service inpatients couldn't keep me away I just enjoy
灵感，你做得太好了，诸如此类。是的，我很高兴，我也感到非常特权，并感到非常荣幸能够做我所做过的事情，与此同时，这并不容易，也不是我觉得自己因为做了它而成为灵感的事情。我只是觉得我设法利用了一堆相当糟糕的环境，并试图利用我的价值观，试图利用我作为个人的身份来开辟一项职业，我希望随着我对这些事情更加直言不讳，我们可以改变一些把关职业的门槛，所以是的，当我进入下一个岗位时，我将在住院服务中与老年人一起工作，住院部无法让我远离，我只是喜欢
working in in that environment it's very challenging but again there is aspects of structure within it so you'll have your morning meetings at the same time every day there's routines on the ward that are kept too so some of the environment might be challenging but I've enjoyed inpatient working every time I've been in an inpatient service because I do feel more contained, even though there's sometimes chaos, but even more so than I would in necessarily a community setting, which may feel a little bit strange from an autistic person to say that they like being in a bit of chaos. But it works for me well congratulations on your new role and thank you for guiding us through the steps involved in kind of having a long-term health condition yourself kind of juggling all of
在那种环境中工作，这非常有挑战性，但同样其中也有结构方面，所以你每天都在同一时间开早会，病房里有保持的常规，所以有些环境可能具有挑战性，但我每次在住院服务中工作都很享受，因为我确实感到更有包容感，尽管有时会有混乱，但甚至比我在社区环境中感受到的还要多，对于一个自闭症患者来说，说他们喜欢处于一点混乱中可能会感觉有点奇怪。但它对我很有用。恭喜你获得新职位，并感谢你指导我们完成作为长期健康状况者自己需要经历的步骤， juggling all of
that and then also your steps in recognizing autistic traits in yourself and then going through diagnosis and assessment um you know such a big episode but a really really interesting and useful one if people want to learn more about you and your work and what you're hoping to help people achieve where's the best place for them to do that yes there's a couple of places. I'm on Twitter or X. What do we call it now? X. So Twitter slash X. I'm there at Victoria Emma underscore W. doctor in front of it once the HCPC registration comes through but Victoria Walker is just fine and I also have a Facebook group called Pre-Qual Clinical Psychologists with Disabilities and or Health Conditions that's where I started the idea for having a mentoring scheme you can contact me at the moment through the some of the mentoring schemes that are within that facebook group and also the ones that i advertise on my twitter slash x um but i will be taking a little bit of a step back from some of those things as i go into qualified life but i can absolutely signpost you to the right
这一切，然后是你认识到自己身上的自闭症特质并经历诊断和评估的步骤。你知道，这是一个如此盛大的剧集，但确实是一个非常有趣且有用的剧集。如果人们想更多地了解你、你的工作以及你希望帮助人们实现的目标，去哪里做最好？是的，有几个地方。我在推特或X上。我们现在叫它什么？X。所以推特/X。我在那里是 Victoria Emma underscore W。一旦HCPC注册通过，前面就会加上doctor，但Victoria Walker就行了。我还有一个名为“有残疾和/或健康状况的预备临床心理学家”的Facebook群组，那是我萌生建立指导计划想法的地方。你目前可以通过那个Facebook群组中的一些指导计划以及我在我的推特/X上宣传的计划与我联系，但我随着进入合格的生活，我会从其中一些事情中稍微退后一步，但我绝对可以为你指引到正确的
place thank you and i feel like i should explain that I insisted on giving you your doctor title, because as I understand it, you are able to use doctor from the moment that you pass your viva. But it's that you're not able to call yourself a clinical psychologist until you get your HCPC registration. So if anyone's done anything wrong there, it is me. But that is absolutely what I was doing at this stage so thank you and if you've got any what's your top tip shall we say for reducing burnout in aspiring psychologists Victoria I think to stay in tune with your values and express them and I know values is a bit of a buzzword um knowing your why so I think that's what values come down to it's why you're doing what you're doing and I think that's the thing that can identify whether the thing that you're doing is in the direction that you want it to be if something is niggling at your values is challenging your values you're more likely to burn out so that's a sign so if
地方。谢谢你，我觉得我应该解释一下，我坚持要给你“医生”的称号，因为据我所知，你从通过viva的那一刻起就可以使用医生称号了。但只是在获得HCPC注册之前，你不能称自己为临床心理学家。所以如果有人做错了什么，那就是我。但这绝对是我在这个阶段所做的，所以谢谢你。如果你有什么，维多利亚，我们称之为减少有抱负的心理学家的倦怠的首要建议是什么？我认为要与你的价值观保持一致并表达出来，我知道价值观是一个有点时髦的词，了解你的“为什么”，所以我认为这就是价值观的归宿，也就是你为什么要做你正在做的事情，我认为这可以识别你正在做的事情是否朝着你希望的方向发展。如果有什么事情在蚕食你的价值观，在挑战你的价值观，你更有可能倦怠，所以这是一个迹象。如果
you're if something in in in your experience or in what you're doing at the moment is feels wrong in the gut let's go to the gut again it's a very powerful place to be if something doesn't quite feel right in your gut it suggests that it's niggling at one of your values it's niggling at your why you're here that means it's something to change whether that's through supervision whether that's through talking to a, whether that's through supervision, whether that's through talking to a manager, whether that's through making a move, whether that's through some form of discrimination that's happening, there's something that's not right. So I would always check in with the values, check in with your why you're here, because then that's often the sign, that's the gateway as to what might be causing that burnout. Really wonderful advice. Thank you. And thank you
你在经历中或目前所做的事情在直觉上感觉不对，让我们再次回到直觉，这是一个非常强大的地方。如果有什么事情在直觉上感觉不太对劲，这表明它在蚕食你的价值观之一，在蚕食你来到这里的“为什么”，这意味着有些事情需要改变，无论是通过督导，无论是通过与，无论是通过督导，无论是通过与经理交谈，无论是通过做出改变，无论是通过正在发生的某种形式的歧视，总有什么地方是不对的。所以我总是会核对价值观，核对你来到这里的“为什么”，因为这通常是一个信号，是导致这种倦怠原因的入口。非常精彩的建议。谢谢。谢谢
for the time that you've given us so generously today. And thank you for getting in contact with me to pitch this episode to me via LinkedIn. It's, yeah, I love, I love it when people do that, because, you know, having a bottom up um process can be so so useful into hearing what other people think will be useful and what other people will absolutely find useful indeed um yeah just want to say thank you again and wishing you very well with this next stage of your career but let me know if I can do anything that might be useful for you in future. Oh thank you yeah it's been lovely to talk to you today I could probably talk for hours about all of this stuff so yeah if anyone did want to contact me please go ahead
你今天如此慷慨地抽出时间。谢谢你通过领英联系我来向我推介这一集。这，是的，我喜欢，我喜欢人们这样做，因为，你知道，拥有自下而上的流程可以非常非常有用，能够听到其他人认为会有用以及其他人绝对会觉得有用的东西。是的，只想再次感谢你，并祝愿你在职业生涯的下一阶段一切顺利。如果我能在未来对你有所帮助，请告诉我。哦，谢谢，是的，今天和你交谈很愉快。关于所有这些东西，我大概可以聊上几个小时，所以，是的，如果有人真的想联系我，请继续
and I'll chew your ear for hours and hours about all of this stuff so yeah thank you so much. I will make sure I put all your contact details in the show notes as well. And if you're watching on YouTube, they will be on the screen and will have been when we were when we were doing all the Twitter X. I don't know either. The web address is still Twitter, but I don't know. I like the blue bird. What can I say? Yeah. Yeah. It's not as nice now. No, no. But yes, thank you very much. And yeah, wishing you all the best with the next stage of your career. Thank you so much. Oh, how absolutely lovely was Dr. Victoria.
我会抓着你聊上几个小时关于所有这些事情，所以，是的，非常感谢。我一定会确保将你的所有联系方式也放在节目笔记中。如果你在YouTube上观看，它们将显示在屏幕上，在我们进行所有推特X时也是如此。我也不知道。网址仍然是推特，但我不知道。我喜欢那只蓝鸟。我能说什么呢？是的。是的。现在没有那么好看了。不，不。但是，是的，非常感谢。并且，是的，祝愿你在职业生涯的下一阶段一切顺利。非常感谢。噢，维多利亚博士是多么可爱啊。
And I love calling her Dr. Victoria. I hope that you found what we had to talk about today useful. And like I said, if you have got any ideas for bottom up or even top down you know you you might be you might be above where I'm at in my career but if you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes or things or resources you'd find helpful do please get in contact with me you can either do that via LinkedIn, Dr. Marianne Trent, or by contacting me via any of my socials or the details in my show notes. Yeah, do please, if you're finding this podcast helpful, do please leave me a rating and a review, which you can do via Spotify or
我喜欢叫她维多利亚博士。我希望你觉得我们今天谈论的内容很有用。就像我说的，如果你有任何自下而上甚至自上而下的想法，你知道，你可能处于我职业生涯之上的位置，但如果你对未来的播客节目或你会觉得有用的资源有任何想法，请务必与我联系。你可以通过领英（Dr. Marianne Trent）联系我，或者通过我的任何社交媒体或节目笔记中的详细信息联系我。是的，请，如果你觉得这个播客很有用，请务必给我留下评分和评论，你可以通过Spotify或
Apple or both. That would be marvellous. And if you find this content useful and any of the other content helpful please do consider buying me a little cup of herbal tea which you can do by clicking on the link in my socials be kind to yourself i'll catch up with you very soon our next episode of the podcast is available from 6 a.m on monday thank you for being part of my world. I'll speak to you very soon. Take care. Thank you. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no
Apple或两者兼顾来做到这一点。那将是非常棒的。如果你觉得这个内容很有用以及任何其他内容很有用，请考虑给我买一小杯花草茶，你可以通过点击我社交媒体中的链接来做到这一点。善待自己，我很快就会与你联系。我们的下一期播客将于周一上午6点发布。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我很快就会和你说话。保重。谢谢。我叫亚娜，我是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现其中关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣，有多少不同的途径可以到达那里让我感到惊讶，并且没有
perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我充满信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的，但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。